so the best screenplays to read are just
as alive as the films that they
eventually become the
flow writers need that creative spark
Reuben urslin said he wanted to create a
roller coaster yeah
I agree I fully agree he um he wanted to
create a roller coaster ride for adults
with his take on the uber wealthy
Tony Kushner collaborated with Steven
Spielberg remotely during the pandemic
after years of convincing him to tell
his personal story but Daniel Quan and
Daniel scheinert their screenplay came
into focus with the phrase let's put my
mum in The Matrix
Martin McDonough wanted to explore the
experience of a breakup so he imagined
two buddies at the end of their
friendship and Todd field wanted to
examine the nuances of modern power
dynamics framing it unexpectedly in the
world of classical music here are the
nominees for best original screenplay
[Applause]
shoes of inner Sharon written by Martin
everything ever
ever written by Daniel Kwan and Daniel
shine
the fablemans written by Steven
Spielberg and Tony Kushner
Tao written by toddfield
triangle of sadness written by Reuben
usland
[Applause]
and the Oscar goes to
everything everywhere
Daniel
[Music]
in 2010 eventually organizing and
narrowing down their fragmented ideas by
100.
all right
okay I had I had a fantasy as a kid of
winning an award and going up and
telling off all the teachers that gave
my brother and I detention so here goes
uh I'm just kidding these are teachers
that changed my life most of them Public
School teachers Miss dumeyer Mr Tool Mr
Hudson uh miss Mr Chambers Madame George
Miss NFL Ken Cheeseman mirtatoshi Joan
darling and Edith Hallman uh you guys
educated me you inspired me uh and you
taught me to be less of a butt head your
turn
all right my fast feel I never thought
of myself as a screenwriter or a
Storyteller I never thought was good
enough I have self-esteem problems I
have to thank all the people yes so uh
thank you oh God guys my imposter
syndrome is uh at an all-time high
um I I need to think the people who made
me the Storyteller that I am starting
with my mom who protected me as a child
protected the inner Storyteller my mom
is sitting here somewhere I don't know
where she is thank you for all the
sacrifices you gave me my wife who
protects me every day from the most
negative thoughts I have especially when
I'm writing and especially I need to
thank Daniel scheiner who is my
confidence he is the person who told me
I was a Storyteller and a filmmaker
before I could even say that myself and
I would not be here without him so thank
you guys thank you so much and to my
fellow nominees thank you so much guys
thank you
[Music]